hi everyone this is Jerry and this is
another live blitz game I just put a
seek out for somebody rated 2000 plus so
I should be up against some stiff
competition okay here we go this is uh
somebody rated 2025 James I don't even
know how to pronounce it alright so just
uh development Knight to f3 already a
black is trying to I believe support
this sort of advance about the night imp
honor directed at eighty-five
I've used this setup before already both
my knight and Bishop are directed at the
e5 square bishops putting pressure I
mean I'm thinking III or maybe Knight B
to d2 if I play e3 he could push because
my knight is then pinned so I played
this I'll just connect my Knights oh I
wasn't expecting that so I guess this
fork is coming up is this really that
bad huh I've never seen this variation
before alright and I guess I have to go
for it and of these two pieces I want to
preserve my bishop
there's a bit weird
okay my bishops being attacked I guess I
have to play here because I want to be
able to move my pawn eventually right
now it's pinned oh I'm in rough shape
already he's it he's pushing forward in
the center and I really can't do a whole
lot about it my pawn is pinned I want to
be able to push here so I could get my
bishop out in this diagonal let's see
what to do if I play pawn to f3 and then
maybe e3 I think I might need to push b3
he might end up getting trapped after a
d4 this is already very awkward I'm
gonna try this f3 and then actually if
he comes to f5 I could push efore
actually he could just push here and
then I'll have to take like this this is
already very ugly very ugly point very
ugly position to have to play through
yeah I think d4 here is pretty good d4
pawn takes Bishop pawn takes Bishop and
I'll have double pawns my e pawn will be
isolated basically all my pawns just got
them they just turn into garbage really
they're all they're all pretty much
targets Queen here checkers just met
with g3
ah the move I did not want to see okay I
guess I have to go for it
there are so many holes in my position
right now well if I'm gonna play this
bad position I'm gonna play it being a
pawn up as ugly as these pawns are
isolated isolated doubled doubled well I
do have a light square bishop he has a
dark square bishop so I guess there's
opportunities for jaraj type endings
opposite color bishop anything's
actually his queen could come out here
and pick off this pawn if he really
wants to regain the material that's what
he's setting up Queen here pawn block
and then I'd be in a pin in rough shape
I think it may be night here forces a
Queen trade ya night here force is a
cruel Queen trade or even here which one
is best and I'm here probably not here
keeping an eye on this pawn c5
nighty for my pond might want [ __ ]
might want to come to e4
what to do this is such an ugly position
well not here because I want to be able
to push here if the Queen comes out in
checks the knight from this square won't
control this three three points so I
want to be able to meet Queen here with
pawn push so he has to back up his
Bishop huh all right let's go for the
Queen trade my net is I this pond is
actually serving a purpose its securing
my Knights position I need my knight
here to guard this pawn otherwise Bishop
crashes and I'm in a fork getting ready
to come out my bishop
all right so opposite colored bishop
bending let's see if I could try and
draw this because I am not better
there's no way I'm better in this
position I don't even think checking is
worthwhile I'm going to avoid checking
let's see very well
let's just go for this bishop check
opposite color Bischoff ending he should
just take my rock I think maybe not
alright so hopefully if he takes here
I'll take with my pawn and I've sort of
repaired my position a bit threatening
the bishop this pawn I'm gonna leave on
this dark square so I have some sort of
dark square control this Bishop of
course can't control any dark square
this is looking like it might turn out
to be a draw or maybe I could beat him
on time hopefully you'll think of it
we've reached this endgame pretty quick
that opening was a disaster
well at least I'm making him think with
this move rook to e3 threatening the
bishop what choices does he have Retreat
the bishop or capture my rook thinking
g3 Bishop g2 at this point I just want
to get this rook involved religious I
want to complete my development his
times don't know hopefully well maybe he
disconnected hopefully not
yeah I think he might have disconnected
I don't think this is a position that
you need to give too much consideration
to either take the rook or move your
bishop
my idea is just g3 Bishop G to get my
rook over here or even here probably
here if I move my rope to the B file he
just pushes b3 okay yeah
g3 Bishop here all right just take
Bishop out I have to start kind of
pretty moving so I caught up on time
eyeing this Bishop Bishop here Bishop
here if he ever pushes this pawn that my
bishop could come here and I'm sort of
securing my pieces all right yeah I'm
gonna come here if look check King here
all right my king is kind of safe here
his rook is actually running out of
squares my bishop is I really don't want
to capture this pawn this pawn is very
important for me to hang on to I'm gonna
push here to secure my bishops position
I don't want to be able I don't want to
allow his pawn to come here and chase my
bishop away it's very it's very good
right here it's it's pretty much working
on both diagonals and he's low on time I
actually saw my pawns are on dark
squares here I still have some dark
square control I might try a four a five
here should I be trying to win this game
I might actually just go ahead and win
on time all right just go here try and
open up the a or B file on here
better not lose we got quite a bit of an
audience here let's see on e5 pawn takes
rook here but then the bishop would come
back and protect see if I'd move my rook
off of the h1 square he might come here
to here he has pressure on my g3 point
maybe Bishop back
maybe pawn push here yeah let's try this
alright I'm gonna just leave this this
is my only this is the only way I could
I might like you might want to come here
now I'm gonna avoid the rook exchange
just so I could try and win her mean I'd
wear it says it you played it win the
game right
alright let's go for this I have to pre
move free move again
wow this pawn is gonna fall crap no
my bishop is luckily gluing everything
together yeah I think I'm just gonna win
on time
yeah just go here
check
this was a very ugly game I'm not sure
how else to describe it but I'm rating
and commenting as always are appreciated
thanks so much bye